Speaker 1: . You know, one of the things I've
said before and that I continue to say many
things I continue to say one is we can have
political disagreements with our leaders as
we will inevitably have while recognizing
that some leaders are normal and others are
not.
And Joe Biden, despite not doing nearly everything
I want him to do, has brought back a degree
of respect to the United States globally that
Donald Trump only ever dreamed of.
And this has become so clear during the recent
G7 and NATO summit and Joe Biden's various
meetings with world leaders.
Remember that under Donald Trump, world leaders
were regularly visibly annoyed with Trump,
endlessly frustrated with Trump.
Trump was increasingly just not a part of
important conversations that world leaders
were having.
The reporting from the G7 and NATO is stunning
how quickly respect has been restored to the
office.
Now, that doesn't mean Biden's a hero.
I've said so many times, let's not DFI politicians,
they're just people and they're flawed people.
They're really just like you and me.
It doesn't mean Biden is a hero.
It's just a reminder of how disastrous the
four years under Donald Trump were.
Now, first of all, statistically, before we
get to the sort of anecdotal stuff, Pew Research
Center released a report last week documenting
the huge improvement to the United States
stature globally after the inauguration of
Joe Biden and the portion of world citizens
from 12 different countries with confidence
in the United States in the US president went
from 17 percent when Trump left office now
to 75 percent.
These are just stunning numbers.
This is basically a quadrupling of the confidence
in the American president in these early months
of Joe Biden's presidency compared to when
Donald Trump left office.
The portion of citizens in these 12 countries
with a favorable view of the United States
has nearly doubled, from 34 percent to 62
percent already.
So statistically, when people like, you know,
free people from the my pillow rally say the
U.S. is now O'Shay, you know, the we should
be ashamed now.
The U.S. is embarrassed globally.
No, no, no, no, no.
We have the data Pew Research Center studies
these this Noam Chomsky referred to it a couple
of weeks ago when we interviewed him.
The favorable view of the US has nearly doubled
around the world under Trump.
But then anecdotally from the G7 and NATO,
Politico describes it as, quote, Overall,
the G7 has delivered a significant win for
Biden while the leaders were panned for not
doing enough to vaccinate the world and frequently
fell short of consensus on the toughest issues.
They're definitely moving in the same direction.
And other leaders fell over themselves to
welcome Biden to their table.
When French President Macron was asked about
whether the US is back as a global leader,
Macron said definitely and later said, It's
great to have a US president, part of the
club and very willing to cooperate.
German Chancellor Angela Merkel said to reporters
at the summit, quote, Being able to meet Joe
Biden is obviously important because he stands
for the commitment to multilateralism, which
we were missing in recent years.
That's a direct shot at Trump.
Even British Prime Minister Boris Johnson,
who quite frankly, politically is an adversary
of Biden as a right winger.
Boris Johnson said he was, quote, absolutely
thrilled to see Biden and that speaking to
Biden was, quote, a breath of fresh air.
Heather Conley, who served as a deputy assistant
secretary of state to Bush-Cheney administration,
said to Politico, quote, There is no longer
a.
Feeling of complete, complete dread before
a NATO or G7 summit or fearing that the meetings
would upend U.S. policy, a Washington Post
report added, Biden was greeted with delight
by G7 leaders, relieved that Trump's tantrums
will be replaced by Biden's backslapping.
So let me say it again.
We do not worship politicians on this show.
Biden is a very flawed politician and at the
end of the day, he's just a person.
But to deny the clear difference here is to
ignore reality.
Now, obviously, and predictably, people on
the right are saying we now are globally embarrassed.
That's not backed up by the data.
But what is really sad is to see even people
on the left who see Biden not just as not
progressive enough, but who want to go further
and they want to pretend that we don't have
a night and day difference from what we had
under Trump guys.
It's OK to recognize.
And still to say, Biden hasn't done enough.
Biden's not progressive enough.
Biden may not achieve the things we want them.
That's fine.
It's OK to say Trump was a reality TV freak
show and Biden is a respectful, educated diplomat.
And that's a really good thing.
But we still hold Biden accountable on policy.
It's OK to do that.
But the leftists who react to this by saying,
of course, Merkel and Boris Johnson, like
Biden, they're all the same center right,
neo liberal or whatever.
Biden's policy platform is not that of Merkel.
It is not that of Johnson.
Will he achieve everything he said he was
going to?
No, of course not.
And we'll hold him accountable when be critical.
But we really participate in a sort of collective
gaslighting.
If we and by we I mean others.
I'm not doing this.
If we pretend that there's no night and day
difference between what Trump was and what
President Biden is today, you know, the thing
Trump could never buy, no matter how much
he spent, no matter how much money he had
with class and professionalism and maturity
and tact and diplomacy.
And that doesn't make Biden a progressive
hero by its very by merely being that way.
But it changes dramatically the standing of
the United States around the world.
And that's a really important thing.